بالنسبة لأولئك منكم الذين كانوا الآن في
الشوارع منذ ما يقرب من أسبوعين ، يجب أن تكون
مسرورًا لأنه لا يزال هناك هذا
الشعور بالبهجة والقلق إلى حد ما حول
المدة التي يمكن أن يستمر فيها هذا لأول
مرة أرى أنني أرى الجميع يقفون
أراهم
عندما تسأل شخصًا ما في لبنان ، فأنا أراها معًا كواحد عادةً عندما تسأل شخصًا ما في
لبنان من أين أنت
، يخبرونك عن الطائفة التي ينتمون إليها
أو إلى الدين الذي ينتمون إليه ،
ولا يخبرونك
عن أيهم ينتمون إليها أو لا يخبروك بذلك.
أنهم لبنانيون عادةً ما نرى أعلام
جميع أنواع الجماعات الطائفية في كل مكان
اليوم ، فنحن نرى العلم اللبناني
يرفع فقط ، وهذا سعيد
للغاية لأنك نشأت في
أستراليا وفر والداك من هذه
الحرب الأهلية ، القضية الأساسية هنا  بالنسبة لأولئك
الذين خرجوا إلى الشوارع ، من السهل جدًا
أن تكون الوعود المتعلقة بالإصلاحات
المتعلقة بالبنية التحتية حول
الاقتصاد بمثابة وعود فاشلة منذ نهاية
اليوم ، ترى المحنة التي يعاني
منها الناس.  أردنا النظام الذي لم
نعد نريده بعد الآن لم
نعد نريد هذا بعد الآن نريد أن نتحد كواحد
في السلسلة البشرية التي تجري
اليوم في بلدنا تثبت أن
العمل الذي نطالب به من أجل
لبنان أفضل  ونريدهم أن يستمعوا إلينا
ولن نتوقف حتى يكونون
هنا في هذا الأفق مغلقًا لفترة
طويلة جدًا من بيكي والآن
أخيرًا تم فتحه أخيرًا هناك ولاعة ثم
في النفق وهذا هو السبب في أن الناس ليسوا كذلك
التوقف لأننا لا نستطيع تصديق
ما نراه في الشوارع هو أن هذا
يحدث بالفعل ، هل سيكون هناك
تغيير في لبنان.
دانيال كيف تترجم ما
يحدث في الشوارع ما
يحدث في تلك التجارة البشرية
التغيير السياسي الإيجابي هذا هو
السؤال الكبير في هذه المرحلة في عيني ، لقد
كان إيجابيًا منذ اليوم الأول منذ أن خرجت
إلى الشوارع
لم يسعني إلا الاستيلاء على هاتفي أو
الكاميرا والتقاط صور للأمهات
والآباء والأجداد
الجدات el  derly
الصغار ، الأطفال ، كل من كان
معًا واحدًا وكانوا يبكون من أجل السلام
ومن أجل لبنان أفضل كانوا
يقدمون الورود لجيشنا ، وكان الفقراء
يطعمون الفقراء ، وكان
الفقراء يقدمون الطعام للفقراء ، كان
أجمل شيء.  الذي
رأيته من قبل ، والأهم بالنسبة لي
هو التشجيع على استخدام الشباب للبقاء
هنا ، هناك أكثر من خمسين بالمائة
معدل بطالة للشباب اليوم
الذين فروا جميعًا من مغادرتهم ، كان
موتهم في المساء يترك ، ما هي
إنهم يبقون من أجل أعني أن هذه هي الخطوة
التي ستبقى وستكون
هناك لبنان أفضل وإذا بدأ
من الشباب وإذا بدأ مع
الأكبر فسيكون هناك تغيير
، فأنت تقول دانييلا أنا أقول
لن أذهب إلى أي مكان أعود فيه من
أستراليا لأكون هنا